hey guys i'm ryan right I am NOT ryan
right no this is Jerry Jerry Jerry is
here because I I was just hanging out
with Jerry I was like you know what I
got a question yesterday where someone
was like hey Ryan you should start doing
podcasts too I don't want to make it
like a su man yeah I don't want to make
it like a big regular thing but i just
wanted to do one can call it hanging out
with ryan and Jerry a real freeform type
of podcast you could do it every couple
weeks every month or something yeah I
know but it's so hard to edit a podcast
I've barely like we just added him live
ya know that's the best way to do it
yeah uh yeah I don't think there's much
editing gonna go into this video there's
gonna be no editing at all maybe rock
they don't we've talked enough times to
where we can probably float conversation
let's hope so hey um but yeah man like
I'm just here today because eight how
was your day it was your day okay uh my
name is weird my day was alright but it
was just like I had a bunch of like very
strange interactions with people today
nice i did a interview an interpretive
I'm Dante interviewed me today okay yeah
and I was taught to tell you that
outside and it was pretty cool you know
like honestly like I was feeling pretty
down today because after a while you
know I was watching um the hot air seen
The Hollywood Reporter round table yeah
I think you showed me yeah I was
watching one with Veronica of the like a
bunch of oscar-nominated actress is some
of them are Oscar winners okay and
street one thing they were talking about
one thing they were talking about was
how um you know you take risks and you
take challenges and you try something
different and sometimes you really don't
get the response er you you think you
might get like I was telling I'm Dante
how I have a sense of humor that's
clearly derived from people who love to
just provoke the crowd yeah you know how
like or a button-pusher right yeah like
I love Louie CK and he clearly says
things sometimes just to get a reaction
from the crowd I didn't watch a lot of
this guy but I'm youtube it a lot this
guy's video
and I saw the movie based on him man on
the moon Andy Kaufman story gay and I
thought he was [ __ ] hilarious talking
about Dante for a second a movie about
his life no I saw a man on the moon when
I was really young and I loved how he
would do things knowing it might upset
the crowd but it would make him laugh
you know yeah and I so I've kind of
taken that approach to this cuz I
sometimes I do that just to get it
reaction but every once in a while I'll
just try something cuz I think it's
funny just to be funny and like for
their I'm Dante put together a trailer
to this row she's gonna do with me
called I don't know there's Ryan right
official right the roast of ryan right
official trailer and he got the honest
trailers guy to be a part of it how did
he do that well I don't know out of the
out of the Albert long talk I had with
him I completely forgot to ask how the
hell he managed to maximally right now
yeah um but it was cool to talk to UM
Dante because you know it really is
Dante he's a cool guy he's a really cool
guy and he's very creative and he got
the joke that of when I did a reaction
to the trailer that's always that that's
always super gratifying isn't like
people jump in from the middle that I
love Ryan can't take a joke or this is
that like when when people jump in and
like really like rag on you for making a
joke and then the person you made the
joke to comes out like no no I got it
though like yeah that's always really
gratifying it's like Oh at least we
understood each other what I did was I
was making fun of like celebrities who
get roasted who were sunglasses and try
to you know who did that to american dad
I was remembering that when Roger got
roasted he was wearing shades and try
not you know just do that thing we were
hiding your emotion cuz I was like you
know what there's a bunch of other
people doing reactions to this trailer
now and they're all doing the same thing
they're probably hollering and laughing
and all that [ __ ] so I was like you know
it's about me let me try something a
little different yeah I think this is a
great yeah like just just from where
it's going yeah from as your because I
haven't seen this video so like as
you're describing and I think it's a
good idea okay but no one liked it a lot
of people were really
up by they were like yours has should be
different they were genuinely of seconds
are like you just were shades and had a
straight face when honestly I was trying
not to laugh sometimes and cuz it wasn't
well because okay see here's is this is
it's the real rejects universe like the
fabric starts to rip and bend because I
think people expected you just to do a
writ like a straight up ryan right
reaction yeah exactly because they don't
realize like the level of sort of
heightened the level of height you give
that ryan right yeah Jonah so I feel
like it's totally ryan right to do the
opposite and wear shades and like not
react just like a person yeah like some
true fans really got it but there are
fans that I thought were like true fans
a-- did not care for it at all and well
you should be enjoying this because you
cuz you riled people in englette and
honestly um it it does start to hurt
after a little while like after a little
while dust and being a youtuber you
shouldn't admit that in a video because
you're gonna get bombarded with comments
of like you're gonna get either you're a
[ __ ] and more people insulting you or
you're gonna get people telling you
don't feel that way you know thousands
of people insult you at one time and
that makes you feel anything remotely
negative your [ __ ] like like to think
of the perspective it's like yeah most
people have been told they suck at one
point or another um but from Morand
granted you know it's not in person but
still it's like I'm a thousand people
tell you you suck that it's gonna start
bumming you out ya know it really it
really does I mean you gotta have thick
skin in this YouTube game you do like
you're dealing with a lot of hatred
especially anyone who does reactions
like I'm sick of explaining the pee like
I don't really get bagged on my other
people but I I'm sick of explaining that
I do more than just reactions you know
people notice in the reaction videos
that I also tried it at least give
worthwhile feedback in opinions on the
video yeah if not usually try to provide
some type of comedy with the guest I
have or
crack a joke you know well yeah I'm
trying to give content still you know
and i think you get less complaints
because people watching realize yeah
most people turn up you're engaging with
what you've just reacted to i was
looking at analytics and like people
stick around for the talking portion you
know after the reaction and all most
people i know that people they usually
just stopped watching after the reaction
i think people like like I think people
think like people oh yeah won't watch
your I react to this trailer but like I
feel like maybe the parts people really
hook into and like really enjoy the most
are the thoughts afterwards absolutely
it's funny to watch you clap or you know
get really excited about things like
it's fun but that's like you know that's
the appetizer yeah that's just it's just
like you know I like to have it be a
one-two combo like okay we react see it
for the first time let the crowd see you
for the first time because what they
want is a review but how fun would it be
if they see us watch it for the first
time and they see the honest reaction of
just the feeling you get from the
trailer and or video whatever and then
you talk about it afterwards I do that
for like at least ninety-five percent of
the videos some of them I just do a
reaction but then some systems getting
insulting it's like I'm not a big fan of
this whole react overs crap and react
tastic and all that like I'm like that
member of the group who's like I don't
want to be a nerd I want to be like I
want to fly solo oh yeah and Superman's
there's being like yo Batman you gotta
be part of team it's why I'm Batman in
this scenario or I'm or iron man yeah
like I like the guys I like the team but
I'm always like I kinda want to do my
own thing down well yeah you know that
none of those dudes are hanging out with
Tony Stark of the weekend maybe Bruce
Banner just in case they have some
research to compare but like yeah exact
recipe pilaar not hanging out with Tony
um damn well [ __ ] we're just talking
about this happened we mod casted yeah
yeah of course cool cool I mean you were
talking about you not being solution to
the react asked for yeah nothing I'm
it's flattering and it's cool and I like
being a but the thing is though and I
really don't want to come across
like I'm putting down other people's
channels cuz I'm not I I like what
aakasam does i like what i love what
Tyrone does I love Gator Martin like
these the reason that I even tried to do
a trailer reaction one day so I like
what they do but something about being
under the same umbrella they just think
you're all the same at that point yeah
yeah yeahs modernizes you yeah and it
takes away from your ear subtle yeah
okay my cats are going crazy this is
realism this was like um and having a is
hope yeah I mean like with having a
YouTube channel like there's there's
things that are easier said than done
you know don't let haters affect you
they're all over the Internet after a
while you know you get beaten down long
enough sometimes you do take it you do
take like a really bad hit sometimes
well yeah I mean the thing that is like
these are these are little labors of
love you know and then it's like you
took the time out of your day to watch a
thing record a video edit the video put
the video up yeah you know you gave the
world something for free yeah and we're
like [ __ ] you yeah it's its fulness know
and like a lot people don't realize it
but all youtubers no matter no matter
how genuine a youtuber is no matter how
real a youtuber is they're still doing
this to provide entertainment for an
audience yeah you know like that doesn't
mean they're not genuine they're just
doing to provide entertainment so like
like anybody who's on the internet you
know vlogging or doing some kind of web
series had to say themselves man I think
my life is interesting enough the other
people would want to see it like yeah
and already there it's for other people
it's for entertainment purposes and I
totally think that I am in the right for
my personal decision right the Ryan
writes move for having the personal
decision to like not post that top five
creepiest 911 phone calls la heli when I
Chilean when I said why I didn't do it
plenty of people did not respect the
reasons why I said it as a matter of
fact there were people who were going oh
ryan just said that because he wants to
look like the good guy and he's putting
everyone else
I'm like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about I was telling some of this time
Dante so you can catch that interview
there but what I was covering was like
hey you know there's these were real
traumatizing deaths and I feel like this
show is to entertain and be positive and
fun and I don't agree with the fact of I
just want to feel right after having
deaths in my family after having a
friend who's had several people died
friends of his died in one year and I
know how traumatizing that can be and
it's like why would I want to generate a
bigger success following and viewership
off of the deaths of five people well
that cause that crosses two lines it's
like it crosses into ugly and it also
crosses into you know desensitize the
desensitization and snuff because the
thing is like any amount of you know
violent movie or gory movies you see
it's like it's always different when you
know it's real or at least for me it's
always different when you know it's real
unlike those things it's like I've been
to the museum of death before and I've
heard calls like that in the past and
they put a gravity in the room like it's
it's weighty and it's ugly and scary and
bleak and it's I didn't want to also
revisit that in the Edit like a lot of
people reactors are a lot of reactors
just drop the [ __ ] video when and
then export it you know I like to
actually review the video edit [ __ ] out
and so I watch every [ __ ] second
first before I export to smooth it down
you sculpt an emphasis yeah and I'm like
I don't want to revisit that with the
foot like I had shalina with me at this
this sensitive positive loving woman and
so and she had to leave on the third
call she was just too there's a 911
calls oh I believe we're associates
elite and I felt terrible about that and
then I as I was watching this video I'm
like this this just wouldn't feel right
to be like hey I'm making um I'm
generating more attention from checking
out this like hey watch me check out
this video and some people are like oh
it's not meant for entertainment /
it's meant for awareness I'm like what
the people need to be aware of with me
checking this out like one people don't
know that this happen yeah like we we
are about that in the new it's one thing
to hear a new story it's anything to
hear a phone call about that when
they're about to die I get that you
could use it for awareness argument um
the thing is you would never record a
reaction for that I mean you could
release a video kind of like you you you
already sort of did just being like hey
I got a lot of requests for this I'm not
gonna do it like that's how you raise
work because if somebody stumbles across
the video who's just a fan of your
channel they didn't know that you can
find those videos on YouTube and people
are the only meat now they'll stay away
from that yeah I don't know to stay with
it like but you just don't perpetuate it
you don't put it back and people are
complaining yeah i'm i'm continuing the
recognition of this video who you know
and i don't like how people are like
Ryan's a [ __ ] for not doing it no no
[ __ ] because a I did do it I'm just
not putting it on the Internet you know
so I did do the video I watched it and
and somebody bro like he's a [ __ ] cuz
you probably cry or he got scared and
I'm like there's plenty of videos I've
posted have you gotten scared yeah or
there's like at least five rev like
bawled my eyes out over talking about
something or whatever so I'm not afraid
to show that has nothing to do with how
I reacted that's just everything to do
with my morals of what i feel is
wouldn't be I wouldn't want to bring
something like that on to the real
rejects like cuz it's true darkness yeah
that's true dark I have dark humor about
things yeah but true darkness is like
that's a territory I don't want to [ __ ]
with these are the last moments of lives
and those people like you probably
wouldn't want those just given out to
the world willy-nilly and exploited for
reaction videos like no no offense
reaction videos but like there's subject
matter you do in the subject matter you
don't do yeah and then Tyrone posted his
and I'm totally cool with that but
people have been telling me that Tyrone
I'm not gonna watch his reaction
because I just don't care for the video
anymore but the but people were saying
like he didn't even do is 1 million
subst and like how he said it was [ __ ]
up that someone sent that thing that
people told him to watch that and
everything and it's like Tyrone ER he
took care of the part where you saw
someone react to the video when he
really regretted it yeah ok I'm someone
already did that for you guys you know
be happy with it right now why did this
get so many requests I I I don't fully
understand why I mean the video itself
went viral instantly why and has like
millions of views or something like that
now I mean I get morbid curiosity I
guess but oh yeah you know like it's and
it's like what's the wood it would be
the point of watching my reaction to it
are you gonna laugh at the fact how I'm
disturbed by these real-life killings or
deaths are you gonna you you want
someone to also be like horrified with
you like what the and you want to just
watch the video again and be hort like
why what there's no point there's
there's no point you know like if I get
scared at a jump scare or something's
horrifying in a trailer or video that's
one thing yeah this is this is something
entirely granted friends because that's
all still fun house you know it's
exactly there's no fun in this one yeah
you know that's all carnival games it's
like oh that thing popped out my jumper
oh you know this really gory killed
moral Kombat you know like I threw up
blah blah but it's not a fun house
anymore this is you know it's it's real
and it's exploitive yeah I mean and I
guess maybe in some weird like
roundabout way you know this video's
viral it's a big thing and they look to
you for that kind of thing in general so
maybe people just got upset cuz they're
like oh I want to know what Ryan thinks
about this you know yeah in the format
I'm used to seeing how Ryan thinks about
this yeah I mean I don't mind if someone
tells me I want to see it but I respect
the fact that you are not gonna post it
that's totally cool with me it's one
thing if you're gonna like start bagging
on me about it and like this completely
disrespecting me and I gotta cover
something else about the the I'm
roast of ryan right reaction i did
people like really attack me on like
when I do reactions and stuff then um it
was only like a few days ago where I
posted my reaction to that Mortal Kombat
raka raka video and you sobs like flip
it out the whole [ __ ] time and that
was real there's a very recommended they
tow this weird line of like this is
funny and also kind of disturbed yeah
and then there's so then there was
people who saw this one video where I
was spoofing um celebrity being roasted
and then they were like his reactions
are always so boring he doesn't you know
he doesn't show any emotions and then
they say [ __ ] like as if I'm really
supposed to care where they're like this
is why Tyrone's always gonna be number
one I'm like I never Oliver set out to
be number one and i'm really i'm pretty
good friends with tyrone actually we
talked like several times a month
actually don't bring you know like team
sports into this like it yeah i don't
believe in competition i believe in
cooperation that's room yeah i came up
with that today you should get a
competition and cooperation says you
across your knuckles yeah i'll be both
yeah and then you just gotta get I gotta
get more or more fingers if it's good
i'm just really tiny tattoos yeah so
that's email that was my day today
that's how man I mean about that's heavy
stuff I mean you know like I yeah when a
bunch of people were yelling at you and
telling you that you sucker or being a
[ __ ] and it's it's easy to post a
comment and you're not really think hard
about it and so you're sitting here
going like but you don't understand like
you know yeah and right now I can
already tell there's gonna be some dicks
out there on the internet who are gonna
be like Orion just wants pity Ryan just
want you know he's a [ __ ] and you can't
handle some hater they're gonna start
saying [ __ ] when I'm like no I deal with
it all the time I'm saying once in a
while this it starts to hurt you yeah
this is a glimpse into what goes on
behind the camera yeah and like I I want
to show my more genuine real side
because people think every joke i make
my
be exactly who I really am when I'm like
every once in a while but you get a
video where you get to see a real
genuine deep you know sensitive side of
me but but most times just joking why
because this is where it's entertainment
yeah you know it's entertainment at the
end of day not doesn't mean we're not
being genuine and sincere but it's
entertain but it's heightened energy and
you know was Jamaica don't everyone does
it if every I'm sorry to spoil this for
some people who might not be aware of
this but everyone who does a reaction
video does it they they channel
something intentionally in them that's
real to feel something and let it out
yeah in real life we probably just sit
back and whatever but it's what you're
alone in your house you're watching
something like rarely do you laugh aloud
or you know do anything audible unless
it's like extraordinarily hilarious
which does happen but like most the time
you you just you're excited in your head
yeah it's not doesn't mean we're forcing
it at all it just means we're channeling
something in us and we're expressing it
yeah like that's if you pay attention to
its like just take the example of a
comedy if you're watching a comedy on
your own you might be thinking this is
funny but when you're watching it and
you know other people in the room
there's automatically a sense of
community and you're more likely to
laugh out loud together and when you add
a camera and just the idea that people
are gonna see this you might be more
comfortable and a little more like oh
yeah I can show cuz people might be
looking yeah exactly you nailed it you
got damn you come down try I call you
the N word but I can't use that word no
well I mean it dude probably it probably
wouldn't go well oh and go well at all
yeah you can't see this but I'm looking
at the mic right now has it for the
camera is watching yeah um but yeah I
guess that's uh my details of my day I
was such a jerk I didn't bother to ask
you any details about your day how was
your day oh no my day was a rather uh
next rorden airy and
I just I worked then I took care of some
stuff around home base you know yeah
yeah you get how's her family is her is
her mom good yeah she's all right she's
your sister you guys still look like no
you know look very much really not
anymore I I don't think we I'm een like
you know we're related like we have like
features but I don't think we ever
looked like each other I'm pretty sure
she had a crush on me when we were
younger are you I don't know about that
no she had a big crush on either I'm
gonna go on record and say Jerry I want
you to imagine what I'm about to tell
you right now at this very moment I hate
oh no wait for a no Jerry doesn't have a
sister Jerry Jerry has three older
brother Jerry went crazy when Jerry is a
lot of thing he believed he murdered all
these imaginary people think that would
be a that feel really weird like reverse
serial killer movies this guy like you
know the the big twist at the end as I
command you didn't actually kill anyone
like was not an american psycho but they
leave it sort of ambiguous don't they
they sort of like I'm kind of decide
whether he did or he didn't cause a
technic there are things that could work
about either employed with her told her
by the boy I mean come on it's been like
20 years you guys have seen goodbye now
it's your fault if it go well and that's
not the crux of that movie like American
Psycho is not like it's not like
spoiling the sixth sense words like that
is going to ruin the movie for you it's
like the ending of American Psycho
doesn't change the context of the whole
movie that came before it yeah that's
true so it's like that's a movie you
watch for the journey hmm much like I'm
told Fight Club is yes a bunch of people
ruin the end of fight club night I just
haven't seen it because of that leg and
this was like before spoiler mania was a
big thing now you should definitely
check out fight club it's worth it for
the journey I've been told that
yeah and it's violent too there's not
like a lot of violence but when it's
there as it was pretty good about a
violent is that I'm pretty confident in
in guessing they would be just saying
that fight club liked movies technically
do worse things but Fight Club the
punches and stuff when they get hit feel
very real yeah and like bone breaking
and stuff so because yeah it's like
watching mortal kombat but a more
realistic version and not as insane well
yeah i like watching mortal kombat it's
like it's like if not a real fight
almost yeah it's like watching a real
likee they look like real fist fights
yeah but it's more than that way more
movies [ __ ] insane because so many
like it it's kind of the same with goran
odd way it's like so many movie fights
are choreographed in ways you might not
pick up on but they are at least semi
martial art inspired even if it's not
like kung fu cinema or anything like
that and then when you see a fight that
looks like a real fight you can tell the
difference it's like odd because real
fights are kind of short and ugly mm-hmm
and you know people don't get to throw a
lot of punches like usually one punch
gets thrown and then somebody like tries
to wrap their arms around the other
person's ribcage and then they end up
like getting they both end up punching
each other in the stomach really that's
like how most let's go is people hunched
over punching no real fights are [ __ ]
brutal disgusting no I get the sense
that like if you show if you don't
bother to do that choreography was like
yeah just make it look ugly you know it
comes to the viscera de finchy knew what
he was doing that's what I call David
and she D finchy I called him that
Leonardo DaVinci yeah well guys that's
it for today I don't know how to close
out of podcast oh man this is bite sized
man I mean this is like heavy stuff I
mean is there anything you want to like
oh you mean like short oh yeah no I'm
just saying like you know we could we
could dish a little more I'm Julie [ __ ]
at the end of like see you like before
we did youtube and today
you really were into podcasts I'll I'm
back into plugin I like podcasts a lot i
do i can like especially when you're
like cleaning or something they're like
[ __ ] amazing alyssa do but I I'm more
used to like video formats so that's why
I'm like especially now with the
copyright strike of how like I for some
reason they let you upload podcast but
if there's actual video for 15 minutes
yeah and so well yeah I think there's a
they may have algorithms that are like
oh it's a static image okay yeah exactly
and they can also tell like oh this
isn't a source audio it's not copy
written audio yeah so I'm gonna wrap
this up now because I'm used to that
format oh yeah no that's alright cool
it's feel weird no no no I mean like how
how long has it been has it only been
like we know that every podcast needs to
be as long as dank ass dubs is but like
no most podcast go on oh there are my
buddies on one that's four hours and
when they dip below four hours people
get really upset no I there's video
podcasts on youtube that are through
that like I've seen that at like four
hours long yeah and I'm like there are
people who are watching for four hours
this one shot of people tuck yes you
like somebody enough hey van I don't
know man I don't know what you would
really have been getting into Marc
Maron's podcast with the [ __ ] I haven't
heard it yet you mean you know find a
guest that you're interested in but like
mark is great because he's a comedian
he's funny but he also kind of gets deep
with his you know he asks more sort of
you know deep in life he questions and I
feel like that would resonate with you
sweet cuz you know there is a good
element of comedy but there's also an
element of like no let's dig in here and
like actually talk about stuff oh cool
yeah I love to check him out them that's
great I feel like um we're doing exactly
what podcast to where you're just
talking about nothing at this point well
it's something I mean it was related to
the it was really a podcast yeah yeah
well we're gonna like I was like men
burrito I had see like this would be
this would be cut out of the video for
example yeah I never podcast you can
just you know we're gonna do one day in
podcast reactions where you don't even
see you sir yes it's gonna be both about
having it
gonna be both of us it's a podcast of us
react we do a blog yeah it's just us
going oh yeah I remember saying that oh
wow we're getting a call during the
caucus he's calling you know Jesus leave
me alone I met a guy named Jesus the
other day his name was Jesus yeah that's
what he told me I mean did he look like
Jesus know yeah well not the traditional
like depiction where he's a white guy
for some reason I i saw a meme on the
internet that was really funny to me
words it's a pic of one of those like
ornate classic pictures of Jesus like
preaching to the disciples and he's got
his hands up and the text just says so
there I was the only white guy injuries
and I was like yeah blonde blue-eyed
Jesus no I mean people who I've seen
like documentaries on it they say that
Jesus really looked um you know dark
skin brown eyes dark hair and actually
there's this uh there was a movie based
on this book but before there's a movie
ever in development i came across this
book called heaven is for real okay and
this kid is basically telling a story
about how he died and went to heaven and
italy like came back something like that
um it's like a like a reverse zombie
movie know yet yeah I don't know if he
died I something happened where he liked
men Jesus whatever okay where he had
like at a very near death experience
something like that right and then he he
had an artist draw what he saw this man
to look like we saw Jesus look like him
it looked like a very real like I was
like this looks great actually yeah that
looks like what Jesus might actually
look like so where was this Gator looked
like Clint Howard yeah you look like
Clint Howard I had the sense of humor of
TJ Miller yeah oh my god I can do TJ
Miller but only like every tenth
attempted like sometimes I'll get his
cadence and those and those like
scraggly a sounds down
but scraggly eight sons then yeah you
scraggly I sounds you Emily Sam's a gone
down under break Jemaine Britt Jimmy
alright guys that was I know what knows
i was about to geek out of her movie but
i want movie what we do in the shadows I
haven't seen it it's so [ __ ] funny
it's so funny with that someone with a
Jermaine yes Jermaine and taika waititi
he's worked with a lot and it's like
this vampire movie yeah it's like a
documentary about vampires just living
in the suburbs and Wellington New
Zealand oh cool that's what's about yeah
I know that yeah and and like it's great
because it's it's got their sense of
humor so it's like they're just four
guys living in this flat who happen to
be vampires so like it's it's got a
different attitude and it's it's it's
the rare improv comedy movie that
actually had an editor and doesn't ask
hateful look at 80 minute movie I was
like oh hey like you found all the funny
riffs and you cut when you needed to
good job you know it's not a million
noise to die in the west where it's like
you just used all the footage of didn't
you oh man alright guys well we're gonna
call it a night we strive to the real
rejects you can check us out on
instagram twitter periscope if you peer
through ryan's window late at night fine
at the post office we ever need to mail
stuff you know we should do we should
podcast but periscope them that'd be
cool yeah i do like a live podcast or
like or like a lives that's how we
promote it to get people to check out
our periscope boom i feel like right now
is the time where culture is figuring
out what periscope you know periscope is
interesting anyway guys there's no
closing joke i will leave you with this
a quote um from TJ from TJ no um I'm
going to quote the secret what you think
about th a and K not I what you think
about oh sure you bring about
wow thanks Ryan no problem I don't mean
I'll see you again you'll attract me
into you oh yeah I would love it if I
had such if I had such strong law of
attraction like I really want a pizza to
be delivered here right now and then
like a pizza man was just forced by
energy sources to jism he just gets
dragged yeah I'm compelled I need to
take this part of town to see it kind of
like an evil dead thing after Jake but
but that's what we call telekinesis and
then you're in a comic book no I loved
secret man end of August